celebrity crush Sylvester Stallone you
married your crush that's right what a
mistake you know what you can say a lot
of good things about Sylvester he's a
horrible husband at least he was with me
but as a writer as a producer as a
director I take my hat off he really
knows how to put things on paper and
from the paper put it on screen
absolutely worst piece of advice you
ever got to Maris Stone was it that bad
yes how did you get along with him on
Creed 2 then
Victor because he's a pro I'm a pro and
we do things when we are said like
actors should do we treat each other we
respect our dignity and we have a
workday ahead of us we buried the
hatchet we moved on which is a great
thing and I suggest more people should
do that